hey guys this is andrew for trading
sensors.com so i've been working as a
professional trainer for the past six
years in hong kong
actually on the option market and i've
just started to make some youtube videos
because i want to show you guys how
protraders are actually working
what kind of tools and techniques we use
how we read the data
how we analyze this data and how we set
up our trades
so if you want to know about all the
stuff and basically how to make money on
the market
you guys are in the right place so in
today's video i want to show you
something amazing
i want to show you something that you
cannot find on any other channel
because most people don't really
understand what they're talking about
and i'm talking about here the short
interest on gamestop and i want to show
you guys how to find it yourself
and how to understand what kind of
impact it's going to have
on the market let's get into it
[Music]
so for those who have watched my
previous videos i'm basically going on
yahoo finance
so let me show you very quickly i'm
going on yahoo finance i type
gme guys once again the purpose of my
channel is to explain to you
how to do everything i'm doing yourself
in today's video i'm going
uh i'm leveling up a bit uh i know that
one i'm going to talk about is a bit
more complicated but i'm sure that a lot
of you are interested in the stuff
and that maybe you want to do it
yourself so this is how you
need to proceed you go on yahoo finance
gme
i told you guys the big maturity is the
16th of april and
uh and july 16th of july right for gme
and you just use this data so here you
have the open interest
you have the implied volatility you're
gonna see guys this stuff is very useful
so it's very good they give it actually
because this data is not easy to find
and
once again here an example for the 800
strike
you have 25 000 open interest on the
strike with a volatility of 300 percent
so
now that you get this data look what you
can do with it we are going here to
compute
the synthetic short interest together so
i just you know copy paste this data i
get it here
so here is my open interest
okay so here is my open interest and
what i want to do
right now is to convert this open
interest
positions into exposure like if it was
shares so what i need to do is first i'm
going to assume that all call options
which is very conservative
but which is not you know that wrong i
mean you know most of those strikes they
are like you know
above levels that gamestop has never
traded so for sure they're called
options
and some of them you don't really know
but you know most of the time on those
stocks
people are just buying call options so
it's a good approximation to consider
their old call options
now i'm gonna compute the exposure of
all these cool
options that i have so just for you to
understand when you have for example 100
cool option
of gme strike 300 of course
uh you don't have 300 shares you have
uh around maybe 30 shares
exposure because you need to multiply
your
number of options by the delta the delta
is the exposure each
option is actually giving you and
luckily guys
computing a delta is something i'm doing
every day
this is my job and i know how to do this
step so to compute the delta you only
need to get
so the volatility that is here the
maturity
your spot level and your strike the
formula is
here for those who are interested the
delta is equal to
n of d1 n is the normal distribution
and d1 is this kind of big formula using
the stock price the strike the
volatility and the maturity right
t is maturity sigma is the volt s is
the spot price and k is the strike so
i'm just
computing this i'm using this formula
and i come up here with my d1
and then my delta which which is equal
to the normal distribution of d1
and for example for a hundred strike so
let's start with the airplane maturity
so for example for the 800 strike the
delta is 95
because you are very deep in the money
we if we take for example a 200 strike
we are like you know at the money and on
the 100
on the 200 strike the delta is 55 it's
usually
around 50 when you are when you are at
the money and if you take those very far
out of the money call options for
example the 800 strikes
your delta is only 10 so here i told you
that you have 3.5 billion
usd national sitting here so national is
just considering
that the delta is going to be uh full
but it's only
actually 10 of that because the exposure
of those
very far out of the monocle options is
much lower even if the volatility is
like 360 percent
which is very big they are not diffusing
that much
so now what i do is that then i consider
that the short
synthetic shot which is actually the
positions uh the exposure
that all the professionals that are
selling those call options are having on
their books some market makers and hedge
funds
the exposure is equal to delta times the
notional and here you can see
that only on the april maturity i sum it
up
right i sum everything here and i have
the
total synthetic short on this maturity
due to
those call options so then i just divide
this by
the market cap of gamestop which is 10
billion us dollar around
and i come up with the synthetic short
on the apple maturity
which is around nine percent now guys
this is becoming very interesting and
you heard of this everywhere i talked of
this
but for the first time i'm pretty sure
you're going to understand what is
really a gamma squeeze so stay with me
here we have 10 percent because the spot
is at 190. now
what is going to happen if actually the
spot price is going higher
those very out of the money cool options
are going to be much
more in the money so basically their
exposure that delta is going to grow
all right this is what we call a gamma
so let me show you an example if i put
gamestop at 250
the delta of the 800 strike is not 9
anymore it's now 16 all right still
using the same
formula it's 16 and so the total
short interest on the april maturity is
not 900
million is now 1.4 1.38 billion usd
so it's 14 and i can do this
everywhere so if gamestop goes to 300
it's becoming 17
and if it's go if it goes to 500
28 guys is growing and if it goes to 800
it's 35 all right so you just saw
that if gamestop starts to go higher the
synthetic shot is
growing naturally which means that those
market makers and hedge funds
either that they're leaving their short
interest they need to borrow shares to
stay short but this is not what they do
they're gonna delta edge the position
so they're gonna basically buy around 20
uh around 25 of the market cap
if the spot goes higher so it's huge
guys
now let me do this on the july maturity
i told you
the two big maturities on gamestop are
april and july
okay 16th of july
and now so we are
still at 190 guys and so the
synthetic short on the july maturity is
doing the same thing guys
i'm doing exactly the same computation
calculations
and i have 1.5 billion usd short
interest
on this maturity so first we have
our first answer what is the total
synthetic short on the market
it's 16 plus
uh nine nine because on the upper
maturity you had nine
percent of synthetic short one gap stop
is at this level so it's 25
and i told you guys that i was
conservative here so it's actually
a bit less than this maybe 20 15 20
something like this
but now if the spot goes higher uh as i
showed you
uh before for the prematurity we go to
35 percent
and for this uh july maturity we go to
20
so the first thing you can notice is
that there is less gamma
right you can see that the difference
for a move of uh
300 on gamestop is only four percent
here when it was 25 for april so that's
why
when the maturity is getting closer the
gamma is increasing
and the gamma squeeze is more likely to
happen because you know what
you are looking for guys is big moves in
this synthetic short if the
synthetic shot is moving a lot it means
that you're gonna see a lot of
buying flows in the market to actually
hedge the books of
those professionals that are selling
those call options which are market
makers and
hatchlings so here we have a second
information is that if the spot
goes at 800 or close to that let's say
700
so you're gonna have here 20 and we saw
35
on their prematurity i'm not taking the
small maturities but
we can guess that there is more and
we've been conservative so let's say our
figures are correct so basically a 55
percent
of synthetic short if the spot goes
higher so only if gamestop goes higher
you're gonna have uh
the short squeeze which is actually a
gamma squeeze and i've just
explained to you guys how this is
working so i hope you enjoyed this video
and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys